i didn't know i don't know if you guys
did that um obviously you were obi-wan
kenobi but you didn't know that no
but that you're in the new one you're in
the new store well hardly i mean my
voice is in it for a second i recorded a
little line in it or something
when do you speak i had a camera i don't
know have you seen have you seen it have
you seen it i did but
yes i thought it was very good
[Laughter]
that line excellent
you know that bit where there's a i
don't remember if where i speak no idea
but very alec guinness speaks in it as
well yes i think the beginning of the
line is the character's name is ray i'm
really struggling here
so i think the character's name is of
course as you all know ray it is and um
i wanted a line of dialogue that said
rey
[Laughter]
[Applause]
these are your first steps or something
what ray these are your first steps or
something something that's what he said
something something something these are
your first steps or something that's
right
so they they recorded me saying it and
then they took they found alec guinness
saying
afraid
and they cut the a
and they
d off and then they took the ray
so it's alec guinness saying ray
and then me saying that other line that
you said yeah did you have to go all the
way to tunisia to do that or did you
but it was obviously a very last minute
thing i mean jj abrams emailed me out
the blood and he got my email address
from someone and emailed me but it was
about two weeks before the film was
released so it was all
obviously sort of last minute oh oh yeah
that might be a good idea oh so anyway
it was nice i was glad to be part of it
and in the film you do do the fly
fishing i do do that and did you know
how to do that already i never i didn't
know how to do it before i said you have
to learn to cast the fly rod
and are you good at it well i'm not i'm
scared because there's one line back
there
i'll say yes
well not really not really i i learned
to do it and then
but the whole the whole beauty of
fishing call it that is the actual
trying to catch the fish and that's
passed down from father to son through
the generation did you accidentally
catch a fish while filming no emily
caught my dog sid
she uh because you have to put the line
behind you through the air and then push
it forward onto the water and there was
a pond up in scotland near where we were
filming and i said emily you've got to
have a go come on we were all fly
fishing have a cover crack so she went
like this she cast back and then when
she pushed it forward there's a horrible
yelp and there's my dog with him
it wasn't through his skin there's no
blood it was just caught in his hair i
got you didn't
[Laughter]
okay well if i got you to do something
there isn't a hook on there okay so hope
no one's eye will be taken right don't
worry
can you demonstrate a little bit so
basically i think we now
what it is so right choose a rod i don't
know what them do you have a favorite uh
no i'm not doing it
okay that's just so that's the road so
you have the line
in front of you right yeah
wait wait
can i so
do you have any accuracy
i don't even know if i can do it it's
been a long time yes i'm absolutely
accurate okay we'll look okay
right so so if i grab keane's symbol
from this right
if i grab this right and
put this down here now
this looks really hard i think it looks
very hard because it is right but a man
this afternoon who gave us the rods did
it did it yeah but he's a fly fisherman
i'm just sending you that challenge
oh hang on i'm just getting ready that
wasn't it
if you step down because they're scared
i might get caught in the light oh i see
i will like give me electrocutes yeah
that would be bad okay
[Music]
[Applause]
saying you've never been in a film
together no no but you have
hung out oh yeah i was in uh australia
when i was doing moulin rouge and when i
was doing the star wars two and three
and we used to we'd have dinner parties
and stuff yeah we're all mates now uh
samuel young mcgregor slightly dobbed
you in it because he told us that he
used to jam
yeah his
[Laughter]
i did it's a bit of an exaggeration
we're usually drunk and and he's he's
good and and i'm crap that's definitely
he play guitar and he can sing i mean
you're singing in films all the time
even if when it's not a musical you sing
you're an excuse to sing
i used to be dropping my trousers and
now it's
singing a song yeah
because we have to think i think are
they god no no no
yes yes
here we go it because your chosen uh
instrument is the ukulele
yes
it's ukulele that's i was actually
yeah
type it into a computer
this is the best night of my life
[Music]
oh
have a sip of wine sam have a certain
way
yourself you are going back into star
wars world there's a
is it is it an obi-wan kenobi spin-off
or just a star wars spin-off yeah it's
um it's the obi-wan kenobi story i
suppose
okay
yeah
that's so it's you it's all you
well it's not all me but it's but it's
certainly
will be a lot of me which is good
and shirley is looking forward to it
already i'm ready
[Laughter]
um we start shooting it in march next
year yeah can i ask a question yes
please i love star wars
i know you're still a young man but
you're steadily getting closer to alec
guinness's age
in the original stuff do you feel you
have to be like look a bit more like he
was in the first star wars movies
because you're you're coming up on the
outside track and you're catching him up
now soon
yes totally i mean the the fun thing
about doing them in the first place when
i was much younger was trying to imagine
alec guinness
how would he play these scenes as a
younger guy and and it got it led me to
watch a lot of his
early work which i hadn't seen before
brilliant movies wonderful films that
he'd been in
um and i just had such a great time sort
of studying him in those movies there
was a great film called the cards that
i've never seen about a
dragon boat man who ends up being a sort
of mayor of a town or something um
so this time as you say frank i'm much
closer in age to him and it will be it
will be my challenge to try and sort of
meet him somewhere you know i love alec
guinness i never got to meet him but i
love him through his work and um
it's a great honor to be able to sort of
try and try and pretend to be him a bit
younger you know interestingly the
obi-wan kenobi your braid that you wore
in the first films it was recently up
for auction now it doesn't it looks
slightly less impressive not attached to
your head this is this is how it
appeared in the auction cap
now good game good game shirley ballas
how much should that braid of hair go
for
50 000. okay
how much don't you no you can't answer
yet don't have to all right uh ashley
what do you think oh um 51 000.
okay
uh frank you are a star wars fan how
much would you pay for i am and i don't
want to go lower in case you and he's
deeply offended i'm gonna say 28 grand
yeah went for three
so not three dollars three thousand
three thousand i would say that would
have been three dollars would have been
really rude no three thousand i was
thinking what i would pay
oh yeah because you are you working with
a frozen
yeah yeah yeah i just work with josh um
yeah yes and on on a beauty and the
beast for disney you're doing beauty in
the beast
you are really good at rubbing it in
this evening
yeah they're not cutting out lumiere
lumiere's in yeah
i'm tara the friend i i've been living
with a friend i'm married to a frenchman
in 20 years more than 20 years and um
i thought yeah i can do the french
accent i got there and i couldn't
[Laughter]
so when you take the french and you do
an er you suddenly become totally
mexican
we are a guest vr again
service to the test
and behind the glass i can see them all
going okay just wait a minute
i'm sitting there going oh i can't
do it
so i'm going to have to redo my all my
voice i think you can maybe i'll get
there
they'll probably cut it yes
and then that would mean they would cut
me so i'll do that you'll do it i'll
work on you and you've made really good
interesting choices the films you've
made you know over the years kind of
train spotting big fish all these you
know really good
the anomaly the one that kind of seems
out of kilter with the rest was that you
decided to do star wars yes were you
like a big fan of star wars was it just
so much money what was it no it was it
wasn't so much money
i know that now at the time i thought it
was a lot of money
no no i was a big fan of them when i
when i was about seven i think when the
first one came out and my uncle was in
all the first the original three dennis
lawson he played this character called
wedge there he is dennis i said uh
dennis what um
i i think i'm getting close to getting
this cast in star wars and he went don't
do it don't do it because he's he's been
plagued with it you know he he did about
a couple of weeks work on the the
original three no he managed to survive
all three of them oh wow he was an
x-wing pilot or something and um
but he just said if you want to have a
career after you're 30 just don't do it
you
but he was wrong so you know and luckily
i didn't listen to him anyway so that's
fine
what an idiot yeah
but it it must have been a weird thing
because presumably that's engineering
career you thought you were famous
yeah
but then you did star wars and it must
have moved into a whole different realm
i don't know i i don't i don't know
because i thought i was really really
famous so i didn't really make much
difference
no i suppose it did change it did change
things but ultimately i think this the
film itself was the star you know star
wars was the star of our ones and and
whereas before i think um
george was limited in the technology
they had available so the the the
characters became
you know more iconic in a way and
because he had so much more access to
technology and the ones that we made
that that became more of the star of
star wars was the the kind of effects
and the technology and everything and so
i've been left kind of not that bothered
by them really didn't you visit the is
it a star wars set museum mean tunisia
when you're on one of them on one of the
bikes that was one of my less famous
moments
there's a set you know you know uncle
owen's place in the original in the in
the original star wars film uncle owen
and peru they live in this hole in the
ground it's like a knockout thing yeah
so that still exists it's a tourist
attraction for i can only assume really
serious star wars fans who go to tunisia
to find this hole and and go down and
look at the old props and stuff it's a
bit sad really not them not the people
the place the place itself the people
yeah
and uh we went we were on our on our
motorcycle trip long way down we we were
going past it so we stopped and we said
we should go it'd be funny so we went
down there
and and uh i didn't get recognized by
anybody
not one person i was wearing a long way
down t-shirt with mcgregor written on
the back
all the way across my shoulders not one
person recognized i just found a poster
of myself which i stood next to
for about 20 minutes
not one person but disappointed and i've
heard a mixed report is it true or not
that you you kept a lightsaber
i officially don't own a lightsaber
props guy gave me one no i didn't
because they bought some uh lightsabers
which i like they're pretty brilliant
okay
no oh that one's on already oh hang on
oh no you have to know what you're doing
with these you see you do though
is which one would you like which one
looks like yours um the one in the
middle is i think uh the the one i use
that's that's alec guinness one oh
they're the shores yeah yeah oh my god
these are really nice it's amazing how
do you turn up can you bang them against
each other will they break oh no they
won't
but you make the sound effects yourself
do you want to do you want one not at
all
come on there you go there go go go
you get a good sword oh look at that
what that's fantastic but can you make
the noises oh can i is it true that you
did this thing
i'm sure you could ask this a thousand
times yeah
like in rocket they did this in rocky as
well
where
they had to you would make the sound
effect yourselves
so they had to go back and like sound
was a nightmare because it was a bunch
of people going
no it wasn't
to begin with it was quite difficult not
to make the sound
yeah and also when it goes away because
it makes that nice
noise when it goes down oh yes
have you heard that in rocky the partly
like the in the first film particularly
it's just loads of sound effects of
sylvester still all good
okay let's do like let's have the lights
down let the lights down because you
have to you have to start them up oh
okay so off off
how would you do that
[Applause]
you're so good at it i did i spent
months doing it
mine keeps going off i want to twirl it
i could
[Applause]
how much are the costs 150 quid each
if i
are you going to kick it if i show you
something can you get over do it over
here hang on i'll throw this here wait
who's who
you just there you go
actually i should be can you can you
throw a ball chris
i would not be like that i can't throw
it down
you go you go you go okay okay here we
go
all right we're good let's baseball it
baseball it's dead okay
yay
what are you going to do with them you
can have them if you want to well we
could sign them and give them to chad
you take yourself
that's
sit here like this or the rest of the
interview
like a snicker player
[Music]
you